on a entendu ton dit laisse les parler
tu évoques les rumeurs que les gens
peuvent raconter sur toi alors il ya eu
et j'ai donné les rumeurs qui sont dans
tes paroles tu nous dises c'était
surtout pas il ya une rumeur qui dit que
tu étais un fidèle du raffinage non non
ça va ils ont appris il ya deux ans que
j'étais marié donc donc calmos sera
mauvais temarii t il j'avais pas
témoigné touche aussi le cdr fois oui
j'avais oublié le temps 2 1 coiffée
couleur taupe qui marque déjà fait ça
fait deux ans à 12 ans connerie mais ça
fait deux ans que j'ai dit disons sans
le dire mais je suis pas en fait ce que
c'est quand tu es quand tu fais la paire
mono dote d'un entretien à coeur qui est
ton album tu as envie qu'on parle de
mios l'album n'y a pas de pas de quoi
avoir envie de le dire il ya deux ans à
la fête ces jeux je me suis fait avoir
en fait j'étais avec cogeco et c'est un
ami et on parlait à la radio et le
problème c'est que j'ai parlé comme s'il
n'y avait pas la radio j'espère que ça
arrivera jamais jean-michel mais un fait
déjà il le fait déjà
ouais c'est vrai 2 il ya une rumeur qui
dit que tu es gay tu es tu as tu le dis
dans ta chanson oui vous pouvez mentir
en 2013
mais qui dit quoi non mais n'y a pas eu
était gay non666 dans ton titre mais
c'est normal tu dis tu dois partir du
moment où tu dis que la personne soit
les gens sans s'interroger c'est logique
moi je trouve que l'interrogation est
normal obligé de démentir c'est fou ça
quand j'ai pas démenti les juges ont
marre et posé la question j'ai fait non
web sémantique et voilà une rumeur qui
dit que tu te raconte de ouf en dehors
des plateaux télé ça d'horreur c'est
faux ouais c'est faux moi je te confirme
c'est fou une rumeur qui dit qu'une
relation amoureuse avec un pipole mais
une rumeur comme quoi j'avais été en
couple et capucine adav non non ça en
fait ces notes mais non ça vous est déjà
passée j'étais déjà mariées mais en fait
c'est ça le wifi en plus ton père il
fait quoi dans le mieux mais les
jardiniers
[Rires]
à moins que ton père c'est kevin
jardiland
franchement si non c'est pas beaucoup
oui en fait c'est que si on avait été
contacté par un journal people pour
faire semblant
non oui comme vous verrez bien ensemble
pour faire un petit peu de promo c'est
ça mais j'ai pas compris le moi je suis
même problème avec qui on va avec
jennifer aniston
non non c'est pas crédible ont boosté la
carrière de jennifer aniston elle avait
besoin d'amis de friends il ya une
rumeur qui dit qu'il ya quelques années
tu as un look très particulier
ce pas une rumeur mais les rumeurs parce
que justement on allait on a les photos
de trois de ses anciens look ah oui et
qui ne vais pas bien évolué tt champion
bat tuning gt gt sur une tentative de
jeu change de couleur de cheveux à la
comme moi bah ouais mais c'est alors
après on a eu nos on était sur la même
sur la même on était en dépression je
pense avoir lieu ah ouais non ça m'a
encore c'est la moins sociale collier
qui se fait plus depuis depuis laspalès
d'ailleurs bethabet savez botero berne